so as we were going into production for
yesterday's show robert muller
spoke robert muller issued a statement
he spoke publicly for the first time
since the publication of the Moller
report and it very quickly became a
breaking and major story in and of
itself but also because of the reactions
that it triggered from president Donald
Trump himself from Fox News anchor Brett
Beier all of which we'll get to a little
bit later but the bottom line is that it
was announced yesterday that Robert
Muller would be issuing a statement
special prosecutor he and did indeed did
issue that statement he spoke publicly
and he confirmed that he could not clear
and has not cleared President Donald
Trump of criminal wrongdoing period now
a lot of my audience hopefully read the
Moller report and if you read the Moller
report noting that Robert Muller said
yesterday would come as a surprise to
those who were operating on the basis of
what the bar letter said for example
anyone who fell for no collusion no
obstruction if you bought into that
narrative then when Robert Muller
yesterday said if we could have cleared
Trump we would have cleared Trump
meaning we didn't clear Trump because we
couldn't clear Trump that may have
actually been newsworthy to you Robert
Muller saying if we had confidence the
President did not commit a crime we
would have said so
the reason the report doesn't clear
Trump of obstruction of justice is
because Robert Muller could not clear
Trump of obstruction of justice and then
again Robert Muller pointing out that
the Justice Department won't charge
Trump but that there are other options
again referring to impeachment and many
Democrats as a result of Robert
Moeller's statement yesterday saying now
it is time to start that impeachment
debate on the floor of the house but we
will get to that a little context for
what Robert Muller said when a subject
of an investigation obstructs that
investigation or lies to investigators
it strikes at the core of their
government's effort to find the truth
and hold wrongdoers accountable let me
say a word about the report
the report has two parts addressing the
two main issues we were asked to
investigate the first volume of the
report details numerous efforts
emanating from Russia to influence the
election this volume includes a
discussion of the Trump campaigns
response to this activity as well as our
conclusion that there was insufficient
evidence to charge a broader conspiracy
and in the second volume the report
describes the results and analysis of
our obstruction of justice investigation
involving the president the order
appointing me special counsel authorized
us to investigate actions that could
obstruct the investigation and we
conducted that investigation and we kept
the office of the acting Attorney
General apprised of the progress of our
work and as set forth in the report
after that investigation if we had had
confidence that the president clearly
did not commit a crime we would have
said so Moeller also announced that he's
retiring resigned resigning his position
as special prosecutor
retiring from the Justice Department
sort of very formally ending his role as
special prosecutor so on the one hand
major breaking news special counsel
saying I can't clear Trump on the other
hand nothing surprising at all if you
read the Moller report if instead of
listening to the William bar or to trump
or Trump's kids or Fox News or Sean
Hannity you would know already that the
president was not cleared of obstruction
by molars investigation bottom line in
all likelihood Donald from committed the
crime multiple counts of obstruction of
justice robert muller did not indict for
political reasons for technical reasons
pointing out that the Justice Department
has this policy of not indicted sitting
presidents but pointing out again that
there are other remedies available and
there are some who are interpreting this
as a signal from Robert Muller
to Nancy Pelosi to whoever that might be
in a position to action
deal with impeachment seriously that
that is the only path forward if you
want to hold Trump accountable for what
appears to be a obstruction on from my
recollection of the Moller report eight
of fourteen possible obstruct
obstructive acts I believe is how they
were referred to in the Moller report so
on impeachment there's some momentum
here there there is a public statement
from Robert Muller people are going to
prison let's move forward and I have
been saying for a while now that there
are numerous strategic benefits for
Democrats to starting impeachment debate
on the floor of the house I do not
believe that you're going to remove
Trump but I am going to outline later on
in the program what the advantage is to
doing this would be and I think they are
they they are clear I know that there is
a contingent of the left which says you
know it could backfire if Democrats
start impeachment proceedings on the
floor of the house it could reinvigorate
Trump's base it could be a distraction
from twenty twenty Democratic candidates
talking about ideas and policy I don't
believe that and I'm going to outline
that for you a little bit later on in
the program start the impeachment debate
get things going get testimony from
witnesses expose the content of the
Moller report to the American people
which as I told you yesterday in the day
before and the day before that most
Americans have not read the Moller
report most Americans don't understand
what is in the Moller report and it
would be extremely beneficial to get
that out in front of as many Americans
as possible and by the way side note
Moeller in a statement also did again
say Russia was working through WikiLeaks
for the publication of a lot of the
stuff that ultimately it was published
that was illegally obtained by Russia
that is something that people on the
right and left were denying for years
which Muller has now repeated and
provided evidence for in his report not
a peep not a peep from all the people
who said there's no way WikiLeaks would
ever be involved in anything like that
well they were they were one of today's
sponsors is impeach the card slap game
you can't slap Donald Trump in real life
but you can slap them in this really
funny and intelligent two-player card
game and you can get it for ten percent
at david pakman.com slash impeach
impeach the card game is perfect for
having friends over hanging out with
family members who have a sense of humor
about trump we've been playing it at my
place I really don't think you'd be able
to find a game that does a better job of
satirizing today's political climate in
such an intelligent way I've had a ton
of fun with it I think you will too you
can tell a ton of time and careful
thought went into the game design and
the cartoon artwork and the humor it
never gets old because you're always
discovering new jokes and political
commentary in the game we were talking
to the creators of the game and they
said one of the goals was that players
might even learn something new as they
play I think it would make a perfect
gift for anyone really of any political
orientation because of how clever it is
don't forget Father's Day is coming up
and when you go to david pakman.com
slash impeach you'll get 10% off the
game but you can also get 10% off any of
the hilarious clothing and accessories
in the online store including t-shirts
coffee mugs tote bags all featuring
funny original political cartoons about
the president get a super fun and witty
gift for yourself or someone you know
whether it's impeach the cards slap game
or any of the other awesome stuff in the
gift shop and get 10% off of all of it
when you go to david pakman.com slash
impeach